.
> ENIUROUT FRONTTONIGHT, THET
TH ORDERHT FROM
FOUR STATE GOVERRSHESPREADS.
NEW , CALIFDT OEOPLEAY
ELDANONESSENTIALINESSES INHIS S.
>> THESE ARE NOTPFULTHIS IS NOT
TO BE A GREATITIZEN
THESE LEGALPROVISNSL BE ENFORCE
BUSINESS THAT IS
AGAIN, ACTIONS CAN AFF
MYTHAT'S WREE PRESIDE T
ORD WILL NOTNATIONMO DONE IN
TO A NATIONAL LOCK T
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES?
>> DON'T THINK SO.
ESSENTIA Y DONE INLIFORNIA, YEHD
THOSE ARE PROBABLY THE TWO
HOTTES T
HOT SPOTS.
I DON'IN GO
O THE UT OTHEROCTC B HAVELENT T
RDICO TO
NONESSENTIALIVITY AFTALREADYING.
AND THE NUMBER OF CORONAVIRUS
CASES NRL IN THSTESESHEHO HAVE .
ONE OF THEMRE LRNECTIONS IS SOM
WHO
PENCS O
TOAS
WE'RE GETTING DETAIHI AREEO THE,
ERIN, IT' STRANGE.ST HAVE BEEN
THE SCHOOLS HLOD. I M NS
BEING TOLD TO DO  STRICTE A QUI
AB HERE.
THAT THE I
A
AYARNGNOT  IS THE DAYCH CALIFORO
AND CONNECTICUT WILL ALLOON BE
UNDERTA HOME. MILLION
AMERICANS.
T THE LOSS OPOTENTIALLY TENS OE
OFSE PROVISIONS WILL BE
THIS IS THE MOS DRA >> ReporteT
SOCIALIZING.
>> WRE TO GO VISIT MOM, I'M GOI
ARE EXEMPT LIKE PROVIDERSRE
ST STRUGGLINAT SUPPL TO KEEPTHE
CK.
WTARTING TO SEEHOSAND B TAKEN .
SO HERE'S EVERY ARY>>ep
TEN
HOSPITAL PARKING LSO
CORONAVIRUSATIENTS.
MIDNIGHT TONIGHT MEXICAN
BORDER WIL JOIN TESSENTIAL TRAV.
THE UNDOCUME W
RE NOT S THEMO
MEXI BAC
OWUN
>>ep
ESIO FOR THEIR FEMPLOYMENT.HA I
GURE.
ALTERAL SNT
SUSPENDED, TAX
D MONTHSULY 15thS IS NOT A PERN
MOMENT IN TIME
>> Repte ITWE DON'T KNOW.
THORE.A. HE THINKS COULD BE JUSY
OFEWORAN
MPLEMENTING A SIMILAR STAYT EW L
WE KNOW PROBLEMS.
REAKING NEWRE,ONE IICASTEDPOSI..
WHAT CAN YOU TELL
>>epS ISLY THESEST WE'VE SEEN IT
COME TO THWEG.
'RHEIDENT'
GHN VICEIDENT'S OFFICE
TESTED POSITIVRTROVERSY. WHO THE
INDIVIDUAL  THED CONTACT
WITH THEICE PR
IN RECYS,
THAY FOLLOWING
THOSE CDCGUN
THEY'R TO FIGURE
DID HAVECT THAT C
ACT WIT TPRESIDENT, OF THE  HER
AOE, A SEPARATG
AND ESSENTIALROSS THE
STREET
IT'S NOT SOMEONEECESSARILY
WAEST
LOT, BUT WE DON'T KNOW FOR
D POINT OUT THIS COM THE S
DAUGHTER AND SENIOR ADVI
IVANKA TRUMPET BACK TO
THE WHITE HOUSE AFTER
BEORMED S ASTORONAVIRUS. GOTULTT
CAME IN CONTACT  A SIOLIAN OFFI.
WE HSE T HOME ITE EV WORKING
SIDE THE WHITE HO WANT.W
WILLIAMSHAFNER.
I APPRECIATE YOUTH THIS NEWS K S
THE VIDENT'S OFFICE.
AFFER THERE HSO YNOW, DOES THIS
CHPLE, THE
PRESIDENTNDPRESIDENTOULD NOGETHT
WAY,ERIN.
YOU WOULDN'T WANT
EXPOSED.
YOUAN VICE XPOSED
HE IS
THINK THEY SHOULD
INSTITE YE I'M SOU AS WE
KN ISH M
WIDESPREAD THAN ANY
INDICATES BECAUSE THERETING. WH
THIS YOU NOW ACTUALLY HAVE THIS
IN THEE IDT'  KNOW
MEETINGS OFTHEY
STANDDE BY SIDE ONTHE PLAOR T
EISEAT D IN CHARG OF
FE DISEASES.
>> ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT
WAS A BIT OF A OW NOW
THIRIGHT TRE THERE WERE UNBELIEN
THE COUNY  M
>> SO NOWE AT RDER WHICH AFFECT
AMERICANS ACROSSRNORS ARE TEL TR
ANDIOUSER.
W
I REDICT ILD W .
>> ANDHAT'S BECAUSE Y THINKAT T
ANTICIPATING HIG WHAT
REALT OURHOSPITALS.T'S HOPE THA
SEE WT'
THAT MAY BE
HAVE T EXT THESE RESTRICTIONS .
>>AT LOCK T THAT IS NOT
CESSARIL
ERENCES MIDWEST ANDMA PR OF THEE
HT OR NOT?
ELRATI
HEALTH TSPONSIBILITY OF EAC
INDIVIDUAL STATE. IHITE I TI THO
MAHA OUGHT TO
CONSIDER IN SEE
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU A
FFECTS E PERSONAY THEY'RE FLINO
SI F
THE DIRECTOR O,OTE,TH TIME IT'S
THE NGERLSO
YOUDFOU IT.THASIERONE FOR
PEOPLE.CONCERN ISAL HEALTHEALTHD
HONS O RISKCOURSE IT'S VE SERIOV
THEIRPLN
THEIR OWN ITY, HOSPITALS
STRUGGLINGE  THESENG WITHINOU WS
F DE PENIVIAUSE TCETIME. F